clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci abonne toi
[Musique]
un repas d'affaires
un bate un dîner en ville une fête entre
amis dtc vous donne les moyens de
briller en société avec huit nouvelles
infos sur la santé que les gens ne
connaissent pas ces cadeaux aujourd'hui
c'est la deuxième partie et on commence
tout de suite avec
mumbai 250 mille fois dans ma vie mais
est-ce que vous êtes déjà demandé à quoi
ça sert de bayer bon de toute façon
maintenant vous vous demandez donc on
dira au début on m'a dit que j'étais
pour bien oxygéné notre cerveau mais en
fait non ensuite on a pensé que c'était
pour refroidir notre cerveau quand ils
surchauffe mais en fait
pas sûr en fait bâiller ça sert à rester
efficace c'est-à-dire un vigilant on
bâille quand on est fatigués ou quand on
s'ennuie et ça nous met un coup de fouet
deux détendue on va y quand on est
stressé et du coup sa relaxe les muscles
d'ailleurs essayé de vous forcer à payer
la prochaine fois que vous serez mon
stress
vous verrez 3 c'est moins connu mais on
balaie aussi quand on a faim c'est comme
une alerte qui nous dit attention là
faudrait peut-être penser à manger parce
que c'est bien d'être vigilants et
détendue mais si on a rien dans le
ventre
on n'est pas efficaces 4 certains
animaux by aussi avant de s'accoupler
alors perso chez des humains je n'ai
jamais vu ça pas sûr que je l'aurais
bien privé
ça à l'époque on ne sent plus rien quand
on a commis de la bouger c'est une odeur
c'est des substances chimiques
on appelle ça des molécules odorantes et
pour qu'on les sent qu'il faut d'abord
qu'elle rentre dans notre nez avec l'air
qu'on respire moi parce qu'au fond d'eux
maintenait tout en haut il ya une toute
petite zone qui est tapissé d'un tissu
hyper particulier et dans ce tissu il ya
des neurones récepteurs des capteurs si
vous voulez y en a 400 types différents
qui s'activent en fonction des molécules
qui arrivent et qui transmettent les
informations au cerveau et après le
cerveau il décide de ce que ça semble
sauf que le virus qui s'attaque pile à
cette petite zone pas aux récepteurs
directement
il se fixe sur les cellules qui lie à
tout autour du cou ça crée une
inflammation ça gonfle et sa comprime
les capteurs les capteurs quand ils sont
compris mais ils marchent plus donc ils
transmettent plus d'infos au cerveau et
le cerveau aussi la pas d'infos il
décide que ça sans rien mais en vrai
fait qu'à la fin ça sent quand même les
autres vont se rendre compte si vous
[Musique]
en effet le fichier des empreintes
digitales et bas bientôt il pourrait y
avoir le fichier des odeurs corporelles
si si je vous jure notre odeur
corporelle c'est un cocktail de plein de
substances chimiques celles rejetées par
les bactéries commun sur la peau c'est
lié à ce qu'on mange c'est lié aux
maladies qu'on a au médicament comprend
et sait qu'il ya aussi doux phéromones
well le truc les animaux sécrète pour
prévenir les autres clients un danger ou
qu'ils ont besoin de se reproduire à
lormont a aussi on s'en sert plus trop
masculin non là nous téléphonent et
yacine d'heure mais au mandat et même si
on les sent pas vraiment elles font
partie de notre odeur corporelle de
notre cocktail et ce cocktail il est
unique comme nos empreintes digitales
du coup la police scientifique elle est
en train d'essayer de mettre au point un
moyen de capter les odeurs corporelles
sur les scènes de crime pour les
comparer et choper des suspects ils
appellent ça l'empreinte olfactives à
les experts ce avec mon style est dans
j'avais remarqué qu'on fait ça quand on
est énervé ça me rend dingue
à quel moment ça calme c'est
complètement con et evans ont en fait
quand on s'appuie sur les yeux à travers
les poker sinon ça pique
quand on s'appuie sur les yeux ça
provoque deux choses notre coeur
ralentit et notre tension diminue et
comme ces deux trucs qui ont tendance à
monter quand on fait des repas du coup
en quelque sorte ça calme c'est pas un
truc mystic earth est un réflexe le
réflexe au culot cardiaque
parce que quand on appuie sur les yeux
c'est stimulant r le nerf vague est le
nerf vague il agit sur pas mal de trucs
et notamment sur notre coeur comme
maintenant donc le nerf vague qui arrive
à ralentir tout ça mais attention si on
titille un peu trop il peut nous coller
un malaise un malaise vagal
quand tu auras son monde du coup il vaut
mieux éviter d'appuyer trop fort ou trop
longtemps faut pas jouer avec ça vaut
mieux trouver un autre moyen de se
calmer tout court en fait
quel rapport entre jones ne tue
quelqu'un et la reine d'angleterre
j'avoue que c'est pas clair je vous
raconte vous savez ça fait pas si
longtemps que ça qu'on fait caca dans
les toilettes dans l'egypte antique ont
creusé dans des vases pour ça m'est
arrivé aussi mais c'était une soirée les
toilettes étaient prises
bref dans la grèce antique on faisait ça
dans des pots ou en plein air et au fur
et à mesure des années des gens ou
inventer les trucs pour pouvoir quand tu
es tranquille à la maison
mais ce qui a révolutionné le croate
business et l'invention de la chasse
d'eau et c'est incorrect a eu l'idée
poweo est la reine elizabeth 1 elle
était très gênée par l'odeur de son
propre cas
même le kaka drenthe ça sent pas très
bon donc il ya un de ses potes le poète
john harrington qui a inventé un système
avec une culture et des robinets pour
évacuer tout ça
au début ça marchait pas très bien mais
la reine était contente et on a un peu
amélioré le système depuis et ce fameux
john harrington et va s'élancer de kit
harrington qui joue john snow dans game
of thrones je voulais je sens que winter
is coming
ça vous était arrivé d'abord le hockey
pas réussir à faire passer ça rend
dingue j'ai un truc pour le hockey on
dit aussi les mieux claudie fresneau
glottique c'est les muscles
respiratoires genre le diaphragme là
qu'ils se contractent tout d'un coup et
qui expulse de l'air brutalement et les
pilotes au fond de la gorge qui se ferme
du coup que ça passe pas bien et ça fait
vibrer les cordes vocales
d'où le bruit on sait pas tout mais a
priori ça arrive quand les nerfs de la
zone sont un peu trop excités quand on
mange trop vite par exemple ou qu'on
boit trop d'alcool les nerfs et n'aime
pas ça du coup pour les calmer les nerfs
il ya un truc génial ce maître glaçons
dans le nombril ça marche mais avant
tout le monde mais quand ça marche c'est
magique on m'a par exemple ça marche à
tous les coups
essayez et vous me direz après il ya
plein d'autres méthodes il ya même un
médecin qui a fait une étude sur
l'efficacité du toucher rectal
oui le toucher rectal c'est mettre un
doigt dans le alors vous faites comme
vous voulez un mois je m'entends bien
avec mon médecin mais j'ai choisi le
glaçon problème
j'ai remarqué que s'appuient encore plus
quand vous pétez sous la douche vous
pétez sous la douche arrêté
c'est bizarre bah non en fait pas
tellement il ya même quatre très bonnes
raisons pour ça un sous la douche vous
êtes tenu enfin a priori donc quand vous
mettez vos vêtements absorbe pas une
partie du lien au passage 2 vous êtes
enfermé dans un petit espace et vous
bougez pas donc vous pouvez pas vous
échapper et votre pas non plus il reste
là y rôde
3 il fait chaud et les molécules
odorantes s aiment bien la chaleur ça
les aide à se diffuser les quatre il ya
plein de vapeur d'eau vous savez comme
dans les diffuseurs d'huiles
essentielles
parce que là les huiles essentielles
c'est vous qui les produisent et quoi la
vapeur d'eau elle se lie hyper bien avec
les molécules odorantes et comme elle
monta les amène directement à votre nez
et au fond de votre nez il ya cette
petite zone avec tous les capteurs qui
analyse les molécules odorantes résultat
c'est la fête c'est open bar de
molécules odorantes
donc voilà on fait ça sent pas plus
murray c'est juste que vous vous en
rendez plus contre
je suis sûr que vous connaissez ce truc
vous vous endormez et tout d'un coup
vous avez l'impression vous tomber dans
le vide et vous réveiller en sursaut
c'est nul comme black pour qu'on fait ça
j'ai un bouton sur le nez tu vas faire
quoi
en fait avant de dormir vraiment passe
par une phase pendant laquelle notre
corps se met en mode avion tout ralenti
petit à petit les ondes de notre cerveau
notre coeur notre respiration et tous
nos mythes se détendent
sauf que parfois ça se fait un peu en
décalé notre corps sont dehors avant
notre cerveau du coup ok on est presque
endormi mais notre esprit est encore un
peu lucide
donc on se rend compte que nos mr l'âge
rapidement et ça nous donne cette
sensation fille pente quand tomber mais
en fait on bouge pas c'est juste combien
tout est là réflexe notre cerveau x10 au
[ __ ] on est en train de tomber pour
faire quelque chose
alors hop qui comptera que les muscles
du cou on sursaute du coup on se
réveille
ah bravo le cerveau génial ça s'appelle
une hallucination hippie nago gic
oui le mot compliqué c'est cadeau c'est
pour pécho